ciao ragazzi bentornate non ho puntata
di cucina buttata oggi ci lanciamo in
cina ma all'interno di questa aereo
oltre a me gianmarco ed enrico c'è anche
mia cugina beatrice e beatrice è una
maga degli involtini primavera che sono
il piatto che andremo a fare oggi per
cui bando le ciance partiamo subito con
ingredienti non è più usando proprio lei
per fare gli involtini primavera avremo
bisogno di verza ti attacca 2 carotone
una ci fu da sale salato pepe bianco
peposo l'olio di semi e della sfoglia
per involtini primavera per le cose
fondamentali la prima non pensavo che
per gli involtini primavera a servissero
così pochi ingredienti la seconda è che
non pensavo che servisse così poco tempo
vi faremo vedere una ricetta in realtà
velocissima la terza è quella
dell'ingrediente più difficile ossia
queste sfoglia sono facili da trovare
all'interno dei market asiatici li
trovate solitamente congelate e se
volete sapere qual è la nostra marca e
questa qualora non riuscì a catturare
queste qualche secondo beatrice sono le
migliori sapete abbiamo messo un link
affiliato di amazon qua sotto
avete possibilità di ordinare delle
spoglie che fanno sempre il loro lavoro
ma che risultano trasparenti alla fine
ma comunque buone lo stesso passiamo al
procedimento d'accordo scusante sarà
velocissimo questa ricetta mi raccomando
infatti iscrivetevi a questo canale
attiva della campanella notifica e
soprattutto se doveste farle anche voi a
casa queste cose qui mi raccomando htc
su instagram mi fa sapere molto piacere
quando vedo che in realtà le cui
favorite no noi fa piacere quando vedo
che in realtà alcune delle nostre
ricette vengono poi rifatte questa cosa
mi fa molto piacere molto pisciare
ragazzi non abbiamo detto cosa più
importante che abbiamo ordinato anche
sempre a questo è jean marc 700
millilitri di salsa agrodolce
io con questa amici faccio il bagno
sono molto gasato innanzitutto perché
adoro tagliare la verza ognuno ha le sue
fisse e in secundis perchè ho sempre
pensato che i motivi nella vera fosse
una cosa impossibile da fare è il suo
pensiero di riuscire a farli oggi mi
galvanizza allora no vabbè potete vedere
la meraviglia poi questa qui in realtà
appassisce tutta vero bob quick dietro
la telecamera guarda sono proprio
fratelli sono dei ritratti come sono
finiti trova le differenze non li trovo
molto simili in realtà devo fare il
soffritto con la cipolla o bitonto
insieme allenati prima la cipolla
robottino deserto ma lasci in pace il
siero questo atteggiamento chiuso letto
bulletto della telecamera
mamma mia quanta ne staffa ecco la palla
devo togliere la ragnatela magico e con
l'altra cosa ci faccio una statua del
tuo pene eccolo qui scorticare giusto
ragazzi ragazze mettete likes anche voi
vorreste che vede ricevere se il super
poteri di uccidere enrico con lo sguardo
sono stupito cioè enrico riprende le
carote messe ovunque non riprende mentre
taglio a metà mi raccomando ragazzi
perché dobbiamo fare adesso è farli di
listarelle
ma che cos'è questo cosa non ti posso di
una cosa ringrazio il cielo che non è un
pene sono già dei passi avanti affetto e
l'attimo sette anni per fare questa cosa
non è però è facile farlo per valutare
dipinto adesso ragazzi
mammamia st verza soffritto con la
cipolla
apriamo il brutto quando senti la faccio
poi se listarelle e reagendo
sa che beve c'e il blog ma sony
funzionato e sono felice che ci sembra
cugina qui sotto vedete un like non la
vedeva da almeno all'inizio
l'audio già ma che ci sono pezzi di cose
da lei
comunque ci stanno parecchi folli a
parer mio a cui non piace la cipolla
se non vi piace la cipolla spiegatemi
perché non era buono di carcere perché
sentiva innaffiata non vale oddio come
faccio saltare questa cifra è partita
male visto che cofana questa sì fiducia
e spero mi stanno dimenticando il sale
il pepe mettiamocelo subito a un pochino
di pepe bianco senza esagerare lasciamo
andare giusto sta guardando fuori pilato
alla fine che ha fatto il fratello ci
siamo con molta delicatezza prendiamo
una solida delle belle
chiudiamo equa premiamo in questo punto
dentro dentro
tra un po d'acqua metterlo qui e tac
graziosissimi questa mossa abbiamo
rubato naturalmente online da chi ne
abbiamo rubato la christie non c'è
qualcosa che ancora non sto capendo la
cultura dei suoi lati se guardate da 72
la vita della mamma mia rabbia
chiudete bene i lati ragazzi consiglio
col cavolo che si apre perfetto questo
ce l'ho nel sangue ragazze l'ho sempre
detto che sono nell'oriente nel mio
sangue
siamo arrivati alla fine tutto quanto
questi qui sono i nostri involtini
alcuni che ho fatti io i più belli
quelli più brutti li ha fatti enrico una
foto premiate rigenerati è comunque non
sono tra quelli brutti
non sono quelli di enrico per il brutto
di frankenstein e stiamo a posto c'è
andato contro il tuo zio di susan questo
momento delicatissimo che siamo tutti è
fallita la ricetta già destra prendono
vi prego caute intero non muoversi
sempre di testa di perna è bravo a quel
mondo lì si sta salvando è il soldato
ryan questo primo giro per da telai a
questo punto sia chiaro all'interno
degli altri che si attaccasse che sono
se avesse ancora le interiora dei suoi
compagni morti in guerra
adesso a carini e oddio sono l'interiore
dei compagni
rappa cottura avevano ci ha lasciato 22
praga nella speranza e sopravvivano
direi di frigge di tutti e salta
direttamente all'assaggio io da piccolo
sono sempre stato avverso alla cultura
culinaria orientale ma col tempo mi sto
riscoprendo tant'è che il mio sogno nel
cassetto è morire in oriente punto da
qualche insetto velenoso oddio sono un
po mollicci e rotti questa roba qui è un
po come il riporto cioè davanti è molto
molto carina pietro vedi la magagna
aperte che il mio come presentazione non
è male il mio primo tentativo e comunque
mi ritengo soddisfatto si ricorda
visivamente un involtino l'opinione era
dove a toccare ed è tutt'altra cosa e
chi in valchiria era davanti saranno
generosa se bellezza lido per quanto
siano miei figli sei e mezzo il rave sei
e mezza bene ma non eccezionale comunque
secondo me 7 se lo merita gli do la
sufficienza però perché comunque sia
riconosco che è una tecnica complicata e
quindi sono fama bene
l'odore l'oriente
caspita odore oriente sarà proprio
vicino e hai salvato da cina l'odore
degli insetti che mi uccideranno amo
anche la verza si sente un sacco ed è
pazzesca in maniera vertiginosa scaliamo
questa classifica arriviamo per quanto
mi riguarda a un sette e mezzo ten quasi
8 e dalle sette e mezzo certo e mezzo
sono ben caduto sapore capitolo fatto i
primi due molto velocemente perché
voleva arrivare a questo vorrei
assaggiare prima senza salsa così una
cure
molto buono abbiamo fatto un po a
riposare da questa salsa è una divinità
commestibile hanno perso leggermente la
croccantezza sia un po riposato ha perso
un po di croccantezza ma caspita ragazzi
e buonissimo cortino buonissimo piatta e
mezzo perché si sente che si sono
riposati un po troppo vini hanno perso
un po di croccantezza non mi aspettavo
potesse uscire così veritiero rispetto
agli standard che conosco non abbiamo
fatto otto meno sapore 8 con la falsa
guadagnano proprio 8 più una ricerca
riuscita bene facile da fare è giusto fa
roba qua da davey rimediata da qualche
parte quanto sei disposto a pagare per
questi involtini sono veramente nulla
ripieno con nulla ma che fritto insieme
di colpo ti porta nell'oriente 2 euro
non di più per la coppia lever 52 euro
al massimo la porzione di questi la
pagherei 2 euro perché sono pure i
piccolini darei il mio bancomat per
acquistarne uno e una cosa molto più
difficile a creare invece riesce a farle
in casa ragazze li fate vi prego taggate
g pateri e con questa salsa vi lasciamo
anche questa qua le amiche descrizione
di bottino si chiama harry per essere un
versione sono fatti per stanziare no
però nemmeno non sono fatti personali
insieme come è riunione
il multi uno si chiama enrico la salsa
grifondoro sono fatti proprio per andare
insieme ma terry semplicemente poteva
anche andare a 7 verde questo
abbinamento giusto no perché in realtà
vanno pure bene con la soia involtino si
chiama grid e la salsa olymp ragazzi
come sempre se volete alla fine di
questo video fateci sapere qua sotto nei
commenti soprattutto secondo voi a cosa
sta l'involtino rispetto alla salsa
visto che ancora non abbiamo trovato il
connubio perfetto
detto ciò iscriviti al canale ma vi
prego fatelo per davvero perché se non
sembrano infortuni in zone a chiederlo
attivate la campana le notifiche e
metteteci un bel pollice in su perilla
perché le che andrebbero mangiate quindi
qualcos'altro save entrare dentro un
vaso grande ci vediamo giovedì alle 12
con un altro video ciao
ma non ci credo che un tempo di rap
stavo facendo la diretta aspettavo che
spegne